[Music]
tomorrow night three top Republican
candidates in the West Virginia Senate
race face off in a primary debate right
here on fox news channel and a race that
could tip the US Senate possibly in
favor of the GOP but the balance of
power in the Senate hangs in the balance
as correspondent Peter Doocy reports
today the candidates are already
fighting for West Virginians votes and
in one case with some questionable
tactics there are not many Hillary
Clinton fans in coal country she lost
West Virginia by 42 points so now
congressman Evan Jenkins is out with an
addict using a primary opponent Attorney
General Patrick Morrissey of being one
of them Morrissey refused to support
Trump over Hillary a picture is worth a
thousand words and this picture is also
fake now the Attorney General is
tweeting despicable at Evan Jenkins WV
photoshopped my photo with at real
Donald Trump and substituted it with
Hillary well I've always strongly
opposed will immediate call out Jenkins
for his lying and dishonesty where is
the accountability as this liar tries to
deceive voters Jenkins says he has no
regrets about the edited picture that
picture speaks volumes of exactly what
Patrick Morrissey was he was a never
Trump er he wouldn't vote for Donald
Trump in the primary Morrissey is
accumulating out-of-town endorsements
from the editors of the National Review
senator Ted Cruz and Senator Rand Paul
who will join Morrissey on the trail
this week his campaign argues he's got
the most conservative record of anybody
running and that quote when voters find
out about Patrick's defeat of President
Obama's war on coal Patrick's efforts to
expand gun rights and Patricks
protection of unborn life they are eager
to support his candidacy a group with
ties to GOP leadership is spending big
to boost either Morsy or Jenkins the
mountain families hack has already spent
1.3 million dollars on ads against
Republican Don's Lankin chip who is
still on probation after a year in jail
for a misdemeanor conviction tied to the
Upper Big Branch mine explosion that
killed 29 I think it probably moves me
up a little bit because I don't think
that Mitch McConnell realize
how anti him and how and how the
establishment West Virginians are
Blankenship is now trying to offset some
of the seven figures Republicans are
spending against him by spending he says
seven figures times something of his own
money just on the primary and if he does
make it out of the primary Blankenship
tells me the hardest part about beating
the Democrat Joe Manchin would be having
to spend time with them Bret Peter Doocy
live in West Virginia Peter thanks we'll
see you there tomorrow those top three
candidates will join martha maccallum
and me for a debate in West Virginia
Morgantown actually bring it to you live
from there tomorrow night 6:30 p.m.
Eastern Time following an abbreviated
version of special report at six o'clock
in the story after the debate with
Martha